en este vídeo quiero platicar como una
burbuja inmobiliaria puede causar
destrucción de la riqueza y después
quiero dejar muy claro que una vez que
se destruye la riqueza lo único que
podemos hacer con la legislación es
distribuir distribuir quién se lleva las
pérdidas realmente no podemos crear
riqueza a partir de leyes claro podemos
pues hacer algunos incentivos de
inversión y así pero eso es otra cosa
bueno entonces empecemos el ejemplo
vamos a pensar que es el año 1 y se
decide construir un nuevo condominio con
cinco casas déjame pintarlos por acá ahí
está una casa
a esta otra casa pensemos que esto de
acá no se está en una colonia normal no
es ni muy cara ni muy barata sale y que
estamos en tiempos así también
normalitos no sé si quieres fijar ideas
podemos pensar que estamos en 1995 que
estoy aquí es el año 1 y bueno entonces
ya en esta época si una familia quiere
comprar aquí necesita ciertos requisitos
pensemos que cada una de estas casas
cuesta 100 mil pesos 100 mil pesos va a
poner así 100k 100 mil pesos y que
llegan 5 familias y deciden comprar cada
familia una casa va entonces como te
comentaba digo seguro estas estas
familias no tienen para pagar la casa
así directamente pero si pueden pedir un
préstamo hipotecario para esto tienen
ciertas restricciones tienen que tener
un buen historial crediticio tienen que
pagar 20 por ciento de enganche también
tienen que tener un trabajo más o menos
estable la cosa es que te agarran piden
su préstamo hipotecario entonces qué
sucede pues cada una de estas familias
ahora tiene 20 mil pesos en capital le
voy a poner
y 20 mil pesos de capital es de 20 mil
pesos y ahora tienen una deuda una deuda
de 80 mil pesos y pagan cierto interés y
lo que sea ok entonces estos 1995 pero
ahora imagínate que empiezan a aparecer
pues estos estos instrumentos
financieros respaldados en hipotecas de
repente los préstamos se vuelven más
sencillos se vuelven más baratos con
tasas más bajas con menos restricciones
porque las personas que venden estos
instrumentos financieros quieren ganar
más dinero empiezan a subestimar el
riesgo y entonces llegamos a 2005 y esta
2005 el año 2005 y qué pasa en este año
que todo el mundo tiene financiamiento
entonces pues ahorita que sucede todo el
mundo tiene financiamiento entonces las
casas empiezan a subir y subir de precio
porque hay mucha demanda de casas va y
entonces estas personas de acá no
quieren vender sus casas porque al
parecer como sube tan rápido en algunos
años se van a volver millonarios y se
van a poder hasta retirar vale
se van a poder jubilar bueno entonces no
sé aún así supongamos que estos de acá
la primer casa se tiene que ir por
alguna razón no se deriva lo mejor a lo
mejor que se tienen que mudar de casa
verdad se tiene que mudar de estado o
sus hijos crecieron se van a la
universidad quieren una casa más
acogedora no se puede haber varias
razones pero ellos van a vender su casa
como hay tantísima demanda entonces se
la van a vender a la persona pues que
sea la más irracional sí la que sea
menos cuidadosa y más imprudente no me
quiero meter mucho en eso pero sí sé es
que tantísima demanda va a hacer que
esta casa se venda muy cara y como los
préstamos están pues tan baratos y tan
fáciles de obtener entonces digamos que
esta casa se logra vender en un millón
va en un millón de pesos claro se vende
a través de una hipoteca pero si potec
es de muy baja calidad tiene amor de
gestación negativa no pide historial
crediticio ni un trabajo estable
entonces la persona que que pide esta
hipoteca realmente no tuvo que pagar
nada de enganche vamos a poner que no
tuvo que pagar nada y además
más bien y ahora tiene que y ahora tiene
que pagar una deuda de un millón de
pesos ok entonces bueno entonces le paga
un millón de pesos a este de acá arriba
le va súper bien tiene que pagar deudas
igual o mejor ya pagó un poquito en el
transcurso de los años verdad tienen que
pagar esto de acá que esté los 80 mil a
mejor ya pagó un poquito pero aunque no
tuviera que pagarlos pues más o menos
las cuentas salen que con este millón de
pesos puede pagar estos 80 mil y más o
menos se queda con 920 mil pesos
novecientos veinte mil le va súper bien
verdad si quiere puede mudarse a costa
rica y vivir como un rey aunque creo que
en costa rica las cosas ya están un poco
caras pero bueno regresemos a los otros
vámonos ahora a estos cuates de acá que
sucede en el vecindario que sucede bueno
en este condominio pues mira ahora estas
personas vieron que esta casa se vendió
en un millón claro está sólo son cinco
casas pero esto puede pasar en
vecindarios de 500 casas entonces ven
que esto de acá este se vivió en un
millón entonces qué sucede pues tan solo
una venta irracional una venta en la
cual se sobre paga por esta casa hace
creer a todos
a todos los del condominio que los
precios de sus casas son altísimos a lo
mejor es un poco exagerado que se vaya
de 100 mil a un millón es como
multiplicarse por 10 - no es tan alocado
ha pasado en eeuu en el transcurso de 10
años pero pero o sea que dicen estas
personas dicen no sabes que no voy a
vender o sea en 10 años mi casa se fue
de 100.000 a un millón y tú seguro si me
espero este otros 10 años va a pasar de
un millón a diez millones hacen las
cuesta las cuentas así pero no se ponen
a pensar quién va a comprar una casa de
10 millones en 10 años verdad bueno
independientemente de eso pensando que
su casa vale un millón se dan cuenta que
se puede monetizar eso sí a qué me
refiero con que se puede monetizar pues
mira o sea aquí está la casa déjenme
pasarla para acá ahora esa casa piensan
que vale que vale un millón pues
platican con su asesor financiero va a
platicar con su asesor financiero y su
asesor financiero le dice mira tienes un
montón de capital aquí que es
ineficiente no está haciendo nada
deberías de ponerlo a trabajar y pues no
sólo el asesor financiero también sus
amigos
sus colegas todas esas personas empiezan
a hacer presión para que invierta este
capital el capital no es realmente de un
millón porque acuérdate que aquí hay una
deuda de 80 mil entonces pensando que no
ha pagado nada de todas formas tienen un
capital como de 920.000 pero bueno estos
900 20 mil seguros se puede invertir en
algo va entonces qué pasa con estas
personas van al banco voy a poner por
acá el banco van al banco y piden un
préstamo piden un préstamo respaldado en
su casa su asesor financiero les dice
como lo que sea entonces el banco ve y
le dice sabes que pues va te voy a
prestar te voy a prestar 500 mil pesos y
a cambio tú me tienes que pagar un 8%
anual y eventualmente pagarme estos 500
mil porque el banco haría esto pues el
banco piensa que es un muy buen trato
verdad la persona piensa que es buen
trato porque podría trabajar su capital
porque obtiene efectivo el banco dice ah
esto está súper bueno y pues me están
pagando un 8% es mucho mejor que los
bonos federales o que los bonos
estatales y además no es un préstamo así
como
en el aire verdad no es un préstamo la
espalda de nada de hecho la casa está
como garantía si esta persona que hay en
incumplimiento de deuda pues yo puedo
quedarme con la casa y que vale un
millón bueno yo pienso que vale un
millón porque eso dice el mercado que
vale y realmente así se fijan los
precios de las cosas entonces me quedo
con la casa de un millón y segurito la
puedo subastar en más de 500 mil y
recuperar lo que perdí entonces el banco
hace esto y no sólo eso sino que además
este préstamo lo parten cachitos y lo
revende a otros inversionistas y esos
son los instrumentos financieros y
respaldados en casas bueno qué sucede
después aquí en la parte más o menos fea
pensemos que aquí en 2005 fue la cúspide
del ciclo crediticio aquí todo mundo
podía pedir prestado pero de repente
pasó un poquito más de tiempo y las
personas que pidieron estos préstamos no
pueden pagar porque porque realmente son
préstamos malos o sea no estaban
respaldados la gente no tenía trabajo
estable entonces deja de pagar
totalmente verdad no puede pagar ni
siquiera las tasas blandas del crédito y
entonces supongamos que a este cuate de
acá
ejecutan la hipoteca o sea realmente el
banco llega dice no me pagas te te quito
tu casa y la vendo entonces el banco la
subasta intenta hacer que tus le salgan
muy bien su subasta pero nada más
obtiene nada más obtiene trescientos mil
pesos
mientras que pasó acá con las
inversiones aquí nada más hicimos que
una casa pedía prestado pero pensamos
que todas estas casas 4 499 las que sean
las del condominio también pidieron
préstamos respaldados en sus casas qué
sucede con este dinero de acá con los
500 mil pues en teoría debió haber sido
invertido en algo productivo en algo que
genere valor pero esto se invierte entre
comillas se invierte en pues no sé qué
cocinas de granito cocinada se va a
poner cocinas de mármol de mármol mármol
verdad se invierte en estos invierte en
2 baños 2 baños extra se invierte en
piso laminado piso laminado minado y
claro bueno en tres partes de inversión
pero además como tienes este préstamo
también se invierte entre comillas en
vacaciones vacaciones
la gente dice que mejor préstamo kim
perdón que mejor inversión que invertir
en mi casa pero como ya platiqué en los
vídeos pasados yo argumento que estoy
acá no es una inversión estoy acá no es
una inversión es simplemente consumo
claro bueno o sea tú dices bueno esto va
a hacer aumentar el valor de mi casa y
además me va a hacer vivir más allá del
ingreso voy a aparecer una persona muy
rica frente a mis vecinos entonces me
conviene pero esto de acá no es nada de
inversión esto no haciendo no está
haciendo que crezca el pastel para todo
el mundo no trae un bien grande a la
sociedad o sea realmente nada más estás
haciendo que tu casa pues parezca más
atractiva para ti y para tus vecinos y
que a lo mejor alegre a la siguiente
persona que va a sobre pagar por ello va
pero realmente no estás haciendo una
fábrica no estás invirtiendo en una
nueva tecnología únicamente estás
mejorando tanto tu vida y la de la
siguiente persona que compre tu casa
entonces bueno en esto estoy acá es una
inversión entre comillas es puro consumo
qué pasa cuándo
cuando tenemos esta subasta de acá pues
la subasta quedó en 300 mil pesos
supongamos que todos estos pidieron los
préstamos así y respaldados en la casa
entonces van a decir si tengo una deuda
esta deuda es de los 500 mil y además
quizás de estos 80 miento es bueno más
sanos tengo una deuda como como por 580
mil pesos con el banco por algo que en
el mercado nada más cuesta 300 mil pesos
que crees que vayan a hacer estas
personas favorita estoy viendo que ya se
me acabó el tiempo pero piensa le
tantito piensa que harías tú en esta
situación y nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo para platicar de esto